isabelle le 1er mai 2019 quelques jours
avant l'ouverture de votre procès ou
publié un très long texte sur facebook
un texte terrible c'est cette haine tout
autour de vous dont vous parliez il ya
un instant qui vous pousse à écrire ce
message avec des mots très forts
notamment contre les journalistes vous
dites je suis fatigué de voir certains
décrivent un entre guillemets aux
journalistes en prennent aimé sortir de
leur hibernation pour se repaître de
leur détestation des autres s'ériger en
juge en moralisateur en biens pensants
se délectant se délecter en tondant des
sagas aussi pitoyable que saugrenue et
ravagé ainsi des vies en provoquant des
dégâts affectif et psychologique vous
adresser aussi à ceux qui vous aiment et
vous ont toujours soutenu je suis
fatigué de devoir dire et redire à
celles et ceux qui me font l'honneur de
mémé notamment dans ma famille
levalloisienne pour laquelle j'ai encore
tant de choses à réaliser que je suis
bien celle que nous sommes bien sûr
qu'ils connaissent et apprécient loin
des minables caricatures qui en sont
faites avec délectation et vous finissez
ce message par une phrase terrible qui
laisse présager le pire
je suis fatigué et comme c'est la fête
du travail je vais en profiter pour
faire une grosse sieste ou trois petits
points après ce message vous fait une
tentative de suicide en avalant une
forte quantité de médicaments isabelle
ça c'était un moment je vais vous dire
c'est ce qui m'a déclenché alors vous
allez dire que c'est complètement
peut-être anecdotique
j'étais allé faire mes courses au
supermarché
rien de plus banal et mais un monsieur
âgé tout d'un coup je connais pas du
tout le cas la campagne puisque c'était
le week-end dernier j'étais pas encore
qui pousse son caddie vers moi qui étais
derrière mon cadet et qui le disputent
voleuse m il m'insulte bon alors comme
ils étaient plus âgés que moi coup pour
lui j'ai pas réagi parce que je suis de
la génération c est méchant mais bon ça
vous à ça vous a touché c'est ça qui a
fait que c'est quelque part ça a été la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
voilà ajoutez à ça la fatigue les nuits
les nuits sans dormir l'inquiétude pour
patrick etc mais je vais vous dire ce
qu'ils vont sauver ce sont des jeunes et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi parce
que j'ai été dans un hôpital qui soigne
ricane ce qu'on appelle un hôpital à la
suite de votre tati oui quand on m'a
sauvé quand le chu m'a sauvé j'ai été
dans un hôpital psychiatrique et les
patients de cet hôpital étaient des
jeunes addict
je connais très bien le handicap je m'en
suis beaucoup occupé
j'ai par exemple les avs je les ai créé
avec l'actuel ministre il ya des années
des années mais je ne connaissais pas
les addictions et j'étais toute la
journée avec eux et finalement voyez
vous il faut s'occuper des autres pour
pas s'occuper de soi alors c'est idiot
quand on sait c'est une phrase idiote
que je vous dis on vous disait vous ne
regardez pas le nombril mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais voilà ils m'ont sauvé je
suis toujours en contact avec eux et
s'ils sont formidables